[Music]
there is a lot of interesting new
technology that scrubs job descriptions
for gendered work yes you know because
layer literally the ways that companies
are presenting opportunities yes is
screaming out women are self screening
out because they're seeing words that
they don't relate to resonate absolutely
absolutely so there's literally like
technology is going to have to help us
shortcut our biases because we are so
unfortunately kind of hopeless when it
comes to it's true it's really hardwired
into us to be biased against maybe
ourselves and believing the stereotypes
we hear but then also particularly bias
coming at us of course from folks who
have not kind of done the work around
you know their own choices right letting
us into boxes so I want to know from you
so when you experienced in your career
maybe some stereotype threat mhm and how
did you correct for it when you know
that it may be being applied to you how
do you not get swamped by that yeah it's
like the death by a thousand cuts you
know it's it does accumulate and then it
causes a lot of us frankly to leave
organization salutely like we don't even
we can't even put a death a fine point
on it but we feel I don't feel valued
and heard and welcomed right
yeah how did you overcome that and kind
of claim your power and yeah that's a
lying great question so first by way of
background as a professor at Columbia
and the first African American to ever
be tenured in the sciences since you
know since since Columbia started so
that so that says well I think it's
incredible achievement but also says a
lot about about about even where where
we are today people think I don't
struggle I struggle every single day I
have perfectionistic syndrome where I
work on an article for a year and then I
work on it for another year
and I know the literature that women are
more likely to do that perfectionistic
syndrome is linked to being worried
about being stereotyped I make lots of
decisions where where I I think very
carefully about how I am perceived by by
others and
often times I'll be and say a faculty
meeting or even when I'm talking to
companies and senior leaders and I'm
like well how many comments should I
make about race versus gender versus
religion like am I being seen as to this
or true that so I worry about these
things all the time but a couple things
I know to be true
one is that when you take calculated
risks you know and you to put yourself a
little bit out there almost always
something amazing happens and so that is
one thing that that I've learned - I
really believe that the whole diversity
and inclusion architecture people don't
understand the underlying science and
when they understand that it's not about
bad people doing bad things but about
the structural differences it sort of
gives me hope and and that helps me take
these calculated risks and I think the
third thing is just me personally
knowing like I will feel anxiety every
time I sit down to write a paper and I
go I'm the first african-american
tenured in the sciences has got to be
really good you know this has to be like
great like what does what what do i what
do I do whenever I think about that I
understand that that's coming partly
from an environment where there's lots
of stereotypes and just knowing that
sort of helps me kind of take a little
bit off in terms of the anxiety but it's
something that I still work through
every day and it's something that I work
with senior leaders to help illuminate
that when you see underperformance so in
my field it's how many articles are you
writing a year but in the corporate
world it might be how many dollars are
you bringing in or how many clients are
you going to see or what your investment
portfolio looks like what I tell people
is that under performance it doesn't
mean that you can't do it it might be
something else that maybe there's
something about the structure but you
must have the same at least kinds of
experience absolutely you do I think
that perfectionism is gendered yes and
and if I were a person of color I'd have
it even worse yeah
because I think when you're the only
there's so much pressure on your
shoulders yeah and this is the problem
with the demographics as we see them in
many
Venezia particularly at the senior level
when you are the only there is just an
undue amount of performance expectations
it feels riskier being a positive is
you're at a table like clinging to
something that you've achieved and that
you are the first and so I think that
it's double work as you said earlier and
triple work to not only be proficient
and excellent but to be managing am i
safe here am i welcomed here my valued
here Amaya token yes you know all of
those things that go through our heads
and so that's why I loved your comment
about like who has supported you to help
you believe not only do you belong here
but that you know you're a you're a star
yeah and there are many stars behind you
you know that you're actually paving the
way for I know and so much of my work
with with lower-level employees or early
in career seeing leaders like you who
did make it you know just that the the
power of being able to see yourself
reflected in someone who's achieved and
who is the first is so is one of those
things that I think leaders don't
understand their role model absolutely
every single day everything you do
absolutely I mean the fact that you
router a lot you're your thank you I
appreciate that I remember early on in
my career and this is something that
when I work with earlier early click
career employees I also talk to them
about I used to ask people for feedback
constantly and I would go find the
person who I knew was gonna be the most
critical and I would say tell me about
my work even though I was really careful
so fast forward I've done research over
the past 15 years showing that people
with some kind of outsider status are
less likely to receive informal feedback
so everyone receives formal which is you
know at the end of the year or your mid
crew your mid-year review but the
watercooler feedback which is a really
matter which is what really matters like
ok I think that you should be doing this
or hey have you thought about this or
hey this new something or other came out
and you
hey you probably didn't pull it together
the way you should have but you know
come back the next day that informal
feedback is really what sort of pushes
people in one in one direction or
another
and so there there are all of these
subtle so the way I always think about
it is what is the structure of the
company that either gives rise or
facilitates stereotypes in really
unconscious ways or what is the company
doing to mitigate those stereotypes and
that is all at a very unconscious level
[Music]